hello my name is Dustin Kirkland I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm here
with Michelle Kasbah and she is in
developer relations working on the cube
flow project we're currently on the path
to cube flow 1.0 it's coming soon what
what can we expect to see in coop flow
1.0 so we just rolled our 0.5 release a
few months ago and we're preparing for
Oh dot six which is sort of the last leg
towards one dot oh and we're really
focusing on taking a lot of the the
learnings from our initial users so the
ones that have been with us from the
very beginning key flows about a year
and a half old at this point we launched
in Cuba in Austin a year and a half ago
and at this point we're focusing on
hardening our api's so we've been
listening to our users we have a great
contributor base and they've given us a
lot of feedback on what works for them
and what doesn't what features they like
what features they don't and so now
we're hardening those we're making sure
that people who have installed it can
upgrade in a seamless way enterprise
features like multi-tenancy more
individualized granular security
controls that kind of thing so making it
a robust experience for enterprise for
startups for everyone in between and as
I understand it like one of the real
goals of coop flow is to get these AI ml
tools in the hands of data scientists
without those data scientists also
having to be kubernetes certified system
administrators right that's right we
want to provide access for both DevOps
and data scientists and machine learning
engineers everyone in between so we
don't want to take away any control at
the kubernetes layer that's really
important for enterprises but we don't
want to date a scientist to have to
learn about docker and containers and
everything all the nuances of the
kubernetes platform so we have one of
the first components of cupola was
Jupiter hub and we've really expanded on
that to make it possible for data
scientists to not really ever leave that
environment to be able to build a model
train it and deploy it directly from
within an environment that they're
familiar with and so the idea is that
DevOps has a lot of the fine-grained
controls but they empower data
scientists
to do everything they need to get their
work done in a scalable way that is
sustainable where everyone's happy
everyone's sort of living in the space
that they're comfortable in and not
stepping on each other's toes and in
terms of community and the community
contributions around coop flow Google
fits into that of course maybe tell us a
little bit about what Google does in the
community and where else you see
community participation in the coop flow
project yeah so cue flow started out as
a Google project a year and a half ago
was launched at cube con and we've seen
an incredible uptick in the number of
contributors number of PRS that we've
seen one of my favorite new features was
just a Bude
a few researchers in Italy they showed
this demo of some notebook features so
something that makes it even easier for
data scientists to essentially add tags
to a notebook so that it will
automatically run within pipelines and
this whole story of the more people use
the platform the more they come up with
ideas that we haven't considered before
and the more that community base grows
so we had a really successful happy hour
last night I think there were there were
only a few Googlers but it was we packed
this tiny neighborhood bodega
there were people spilling out into the
streets and it was people from all over
the world
and that's really encouraging to see we
have a lot of big support from from
Azure we have a bunch of eight of us
integration it doesn't just run on the
Google platform it's designed to be a
portable platform for running machine
learning anywhere you have a kubernetes
cluster uses vanilla kubernetes api x'
and the the influx of people coming from
all over and adding to that has been
incredibly encouraging yeah I can see it
and tell me a little bit about the
applications you're starting to see that
maybe some of the ones you're most
excited about seeing developed on top of
the cube slab platform so the thing that
I'm most excited about is part of the
keynote was a few people from CERN who
came up and talked about this public
dataset that they have so they
replicated the Higgs boson experiment
and they used they did that on gke and
so I'm meeting with them very soon I
could actually visit CERN and take a
tour I've been wanting to do this for so
many years
if you've seen the documentary particle
fever it is incredible and so I get to
see that in person and I'm hoping that
when I meet with the team that I I can
come up with like some sort of way to
get them running on cue flow because it
would be amazing to work with that data
set and to sort of help them along their
journey Michelle thank you very much
[Music]
you